so how did the dodeca making better
filmmakers I mean it was a while ago
that he shot it and then life is taking
sort of an intern yeah yeah directions
what did you learn from the filming of
it wow that's interesting um well it's a
much bigger movie than we had made
before you know we had only made a puffy
chair and baguette before and so there
were a lot of I mean we had to really
start exploring more technically
advanced ways of shooting things you
know people are running at full speed
you're trying to you know explore and
show visually you know how people are
winning sports against each other and
you know prior to that all of our films
are really just focused on you know
close-ups in the inner world of human
beings and I think the particular
challenge that traditional cinema
presents to our style of filmmaking
which is a handheld documentary
something is happening and you're
capturing as it's going on there's a
there's an extra challenge to it which
is when you have to do something that's
very controlled you actually have to
make it look shaggy and make it fit into
the style but you know obviously when
you're doing something really big you
kind of have to plan it so how do you do
a documentary-style tracking running
action shot yeah no that's an
interesting DNA and we had to sort of
concoct that
you guys are masters at creating funny
moments from awkward human interaction
so how much of what you write is based
on real life experiences that you've
gone through even if it just looks that
yeah you know this I mean it's it's
always a hard question to ask you know
like what's autobiographical and what's
not you know in the case of a movie like
the puffy chair I would say we were
borrowing intensely from what Jay was
going through with his then girlfriend
now wife and me and Katie were going
through in our own relationship that was
a time when we were in our mid-20s and
it was or get off the pot you know
break up or get married and that's what
that movie was about in the case of the
director pentathlon is based on two
other brothers who actually did this so
so it's much more loosely based on our
lives and Jana actually aren't that
competitive at all with each other but
the intricacies of family dynamics you
know and how hard it is to stay
connected with your family when you try
to be close and how much conflict there
is you know that is stuff that we're
obsessed with because we're very close
with our family you know so so I think
you in a case of dodeca it's borrowed
more in bits and pieces you know and
every film is different
you